where is the acid my staff hears me say
this more than they probably care to
remember but where is the acid is really
the central question when we create a
new dish
when seasoning foods everyone talks
about salt
I believe acid is just as important
maybe more important than salt when I
grew up in Switzerland I was always
drawn to sig acidic foods I love
Tomatoes I love citrus fruits I love
pickles my mom's cooking sauerkraut
roasted chicken with lemon and Rose
Marie she made a braised rabbit with
olives orange and pickled onions I never
knew exactly why I was drawn to these
dishes so much why they were my favorite
but looking back it makes sense because
there was presence of acid which gave it
balance and it highlighted the food and
it just makes food better acid just
makes food better at Eleven Madison we
serve tasting menus 14 15 16 courses
it's important that all these dishes
have acid we use acid from so many
different sources but it keeps the
guests excited it keeps the meal lighter
and it makes the guests want more so
what is an acid an acid by definition is
a molecule that releases a hydrogen ion
and so here is an image of citric acid
releasing a hydrogen ion and this
measure of how strong an acid is is a
measure of how easily an acid gives up
that hydrogen ion and so for example
citric acid gives up the hydrogen ion
not as easily as say sulfuric acid dusts
which we use in car batteries the
hydrogen ion
is is taken up by the water and it's
giving us a set of an h2o is giving us
an each three o plus and this is usually
referred to as a hydronium ion so how
acidic something is then is a measure of
how easily hydrogen ions are given off
and we usually also refer to hydrogen
ions as protons and the more hydrogen
ions and indirectly how many hydronium
ions there are around is what gives us a
measure of how acidic something is so it
turns out that the number of hydrogen
ions in water naturally is 10 to the
power of negative seven moles per liter
or you know in a liter of water in fact
there is 55 moles of molecules per liter
and so 10 to the negative 7 then is
actually a very very tiny amount but
nevertheless this is how many hydrogen
ions there are in water water is thought
of being neutral and acids are molecules
that easily give up hydrogen ions and so
they're acidic and so then at the other
end of the spectrum we have molecules
that are very very reluctant to give up
hydrogen ions even more so than water
and those we think of as bases or basic
molecules and there is a mathematical
formula for this which is pH equals
minus the logarithm of how many moles
per liter of hydrogen ions we have and
so if we do this for water where we know
that the number of hydrogen ions is 10
to the negative 7 and we plug this into
this formula we see minus the logarithm
of 10 to the negative 7 and and for
those of you who are comfortable with
logarithms you immediately see that the
answer to this is 7 and if you're not
you can plug this into your calculator
and actually see that the number for
this is 7 and so the pH of water is 7
and this is something that a lot of us
are very familiar with and if not this
is a good reminder we're using a pH
meter at the restaurant and we're using
it as a measure to give us more
consistency more accuracy we're using it
in a way we use a scale
or in a way we measured temperature so
we took our still water and this is the
water we serve with our meal and we
measured it at seven point five seven is
neutral so it's very close to neutral we
also looked at the manufactured foods
coca-cola is more acidic than red wine
vinegar just imagine that isn't that
crazy you eat that with your meal it's
more acidic than red wine vinegar that's
unbelievable
and when you drink coca-cola you never
think of it as being acidic and that is
why and that's because there's so much
sugar to balance all that acid and makes
it a beverage that everyone loves